E aí galera que assiste o meu canal tudo
bom com vocês T de volta ao Brasil a
gente pousa direto em São
Paulo e aí eu resolvi gravar um vídeo
sobre São Paulo gravar aqui nessa sacada
diabo que não tem nada que define melhor
São Paulo do que uma sacada você de uma
sacada em São Paulo você consegue ver
tudo acontecendo ao mesmo tempo acabou
de sair um helicóptero aqui de cima de
um prédio pegou um helicóptero o prédio
tá todo envelopado naquele Mosqueteiro
sabe você passa ve um prédio assim com
Mosqueteiro Deixaram um cara ali em cima
o cara desceu o helicóptero foi embora
acho que é o detetizador acaba com a
raquete mata mosquito aí pass saber os
quadinho a dentro cachorro latino
ó zangou aí tem um rio sendo despoluído
aqui na minha frente mas ele tá muito
sujo eu acho que não não Desc mais não
aqueles trabalhos que prefeitura promete
eu vou despoluir o Rio e a água vai
ficar potavel até o beb vai passando de
governo para governo tá aqui a gente
passa tem duas Maquin Por isso que eu
digo que não dá jeito que se a gente
passasse viss um mundar de cor lixo
saindo e água ficando mais clar aí eu
dizer não Aí sim mas desse jeito aqui a
máquina ré mais do que eu ri evolui tudo
os Foguete da ré já tem noção existi uma
frase foguete não tem ré por os foguete
agora já tem ré já e as máquin de limpar
água de R ess essas cois tira um pneu
tira um sofá tira uma bicicleta tira um
corto quisesse fazer tinha feito isso
aqui
p p p p da moto passando P aí o caba
dizendo assim sai do H quem se incomode
não é se entender o mecanismo Acho até
massa aí se você quiser se aprofundar
mais no conhecimento desse P aí você
assiste no YouTube aqueles canal dos car
que bota GoPro e sai assim você é louco
tio o trânsito hoje tá maluco mano tá
zoeira liga a seta tia liga a seta aí tu
ver a aquele que eu vejo quando eu tô
rapaz que legal né F mais amigável aí
você às vez ve se acidenta bate no
Motoboy você em vez de de de brigar
porque aconteceu o negócio ficar triste
você tira uma foto com ele é muita coisa
acontecendo é gente morrendo é gente
nascendo gente dando os últimos suspiros
e gente dando os primeiros
suspiros ali pode tá indo dando os
últimos suspiros né não sei vamos ver né
Depende da Qual foi a velocidade do
chamado do socor muito trânsito aí
sempre que com trânsito Eu tenho um
negócio assim eu não tento não arrumar
confusão com ninguém então o cara passou
muito rápido por mim sei lá foi perigoso
é natural que a gente pensea assim filha
da tal tem que ter paciência a
gente tem que ter paciência e já fica
sem paciência então toda vez que eu crio
essa situação ruim na minha cabeça que
que o cara é tá sendo imprudente aí eu
eu boto na minha cabeça que pode ser
alguma coisa boa também que o cara tá
indo fazer tipo ah ele tá indo ver o
nascimento do filho dele tá ligado eu
penso tá ruim eu penso D boa que aí dá
um equilíbrio assim como que diz tem
dias e dias cara as pessoas T seus
momentos não não se metam em confusão
não a maquininha mancha a maquininha que
tá ali limpa no Rei mano ô meu Deus do
céu mano a proporção é tipo assim sabe
aquela aquelas maquininhas automática
que limpa a casa que os GAT fica em cima
tem aqueles vídeos legal do Instagram o
gato que sobe em cima e fica rodando em
cima do negócio que limpa a casa só que
no Maracanã gente recebendo pedindo
cachorro cagando dono limpando Acabei de
ver gente indo para lá e PR cá é fazendo
né sendo acontecendo né gente
conversando no banco da praça final
abriu mecanismo rodando né por isso
quando tem um acidente fica assim tudo
eu não sei o que não sei o que pane no
sistema alguém me desconfigurou um caos
ordenado assim acho que é por isso que
não adianta rezar um santo olha daqui da
altura que eu tô vendo não tem como
resolver s lunguinho s lunguinho Se eu
achar essa carteira do três polin são
lin aonde eu não tô vendo nem tu muito
legal
TR batendo alguma coisa aconteceu não
era esse te a vida toda então eu cheguei
de bermuda só que de shorts
humor eu postei uma uma foto com uma
regata que eu Visitei bermuda então a
regata tinha escrito bermuda aí o conse
respondeu agora tinha que ter uma
bermuda com o nome regata Aí eu disse
para melhorar só se botasse um tênis
escrito boné contribui pro sistema o
mecanismo não mas também é bom se
divertir às vezes tirar uma oninha aí eu
fico aqui no Brasil brico de de
brasileiro uns sete dias e Vou Pra
Inglaterra que eu tenho luta dia
14 próximo dia 14 em Manchester eu já
vou treinar lá e é isso né eu gravei um
vídeo de bermuda não sei se você viu foi
o último vídeo que eu postei no canal
então você pode voltar lá e assistir e é
isso aí tamo junto obrigado por ter
passado esse tempinho aqui comigo
batendo esse papo legal bacana
esquizofrênico né que só eu falei mas eu
tenho a impressão de que você está aqui
me assistindo não sei porque eu tenho
essa impressão acho que é porque você tá
assistindo mesmo então se você tá
assistindo clica em gostei aí se
inscreve no canal
valeu